hello my name's alaska what's yours
i'm willam i host podcasts with you on
the mom network i think i know you
today we're going to be playing a little
game called
true true or why you need to take a sip
you absolutely need to take a sip
which season of drag race international
series included can you watch over
and over i really liked drag race season
two in
england that was really really good
taste ahora ellie
all those girls really really turned it
and stepped up
season three it's so good it's the
classic season it's like really when
they were like starting to hit their
stride
the queens are all so amazing and
they're still
all iconic to this day which season of
drag race is by far the most
boring season i haven't seen them all so
i don't really know
i don't really think any of them are
boring other than like season three
because we all knew that raja was gonna
win before she won because perez hilton
spoiled it for everybody so i'd say
season three but it still wasn't boring
it was still really really good
what's your favorite and least favorite
part about hosting a podcast
my favorite part about hosting a podcast
was hanging out with alaska
my least favorite part about posting a
podcast is when it's over
talk to your friends and then you're
like what are you doing can we hang out
oh wait we can't we're on different
continents
i just like talking about drag drag is
amazing and it's given me every
opportunity in my life
it's really so much fun because you're
so hilarious
getting to talk with you about my
favorite show
is a joy and lovely and you can listen
every wednesday
on race chaser the podcast
my least favorite part is technological
like
instability and distance like
i'm grateful that we're able to do it
like you're in the uk and
and i'm in california and like we're
able to do it
but there's no replacing being in person
2022
we're going on tour and doing like race
chaser live like in theaters with people
now there's
really nothing like that we had a pony
last time two ponies and they had
ponytails
enough about your dates my life we
arrived on the oscar meyer weiner hot
dog truck too
but enough about my date had you not
been eliminated on season four could you
have won the crown
no because i literally did not have the
time frame to stay for the full
production schedule the producer that i
was thinking hey steven he hates me now
he told me that they were going to make
me top three and i would have probably
fallen into the fifi role
so i would have been the which makes
sense because i'm funny
so uh no i don't think i would have won
throughout all the drag race seasons
which elimination was the worst choice
rue ever made yeah when she
fired matthew i thought that was a bad
choice that was her makeup artist
i believe it was a mistake on the part
of rupaul and i don't think it's rupaul
personally i think it's like there's a
team of people who are making the show
happen
but i think it was a mistake to start
allowing the queens in all stars to have
the power to send
each other home whether it's by vote or
just by choice
then you end up with like a final that
isn't as
like amazing as you want it it's called
getting manila
and i don't blame naomi smalls in that
moment in any way
because it makes sense and those are the
rules of the game
but it also would have been really cool
to just
see what would have happened she was
wearing my gold dolce corset when she
sent manila home so it's your fault
basically
is there a look from any of your seasons
that you really regret
wearing no i was only on eight episodes
like and this was 10 years ago
that question was easy for you because
you looked flawless in every single
runway that and every moment that you
were on drag race
some of us some of us didn't have that
journey
all my clothes pretty much on season
five
there were a lot of issues there was
something there but like god bless that
child
if there was ever an all winners season
of all stars
who would make it to the top three i
think raja's really amazing
bob would win let's be realistic it
would be like bob and it would be like
raja
and it would be like aquarium is there a
queen that you think should host a
podcast who doesn't have one
girl we've given all the girls podcasts
oh you know what pablo vittar i would
listen to him
giovanna or how about yaro sofia and the
whole thing would just be
shake my titties shake my titty shake
shake shake my titties
is there a question about drag race that
you two are sick of
answering i never get sick of answering
anything because i
i realize that like one day no one will
care people ask me a lot about what i
did on drag race to get disqualified and
now i just pinned it to the top of my
twitter
it's like six pages on notes of
everything that i ever did
come up but i'm not tired of it i'm
grateful that anyone cares
yeah the same during your season of drag
race did you steal anything from the
work room if you check out my pin tweet
on twitter
you'll see that i stole iron fist shoes
some ostrich feather fans
staple guns lots and lots of things they
made me put back the feather fans
because they were ostrich
and they're like we know some girls have
things in their bags and i was like oh
it's in the dior you can grab it out of
mine
and i was like i won't say who else has
stuff but you know i have most of it i
took it
because i was trying to get kicked off
at that point that was episode i think
four
whatever it was iron fist shoes those
ugly ass shoes that rue try to make us
wear
excuse me i like the iron fist shoes and
sharon stole a whole bunch of pairs of
them
and we wore the [ __ ] out of them i kept
some things
i remember from all stars like we did
that perplexing golfing challenge where
we were like using our hanging testicles
as the golfing mechanism
it's very strange but i kept a plaid
golfer hat
and i kept the uh baby jane
hudson wig telling theron
which drag race queen do you currently
have the biggest beef with
i don't at all i really don't you have a
personal vendetta against serena chacha
for some reason
it's not personal it's professional i
don't like girls around with other girls
wigs
the biggest beef i have with a girl is
probably courtneyak i chased her around
with a big piece of beef you know how
vegans always like to announce
themselves she's like vegan so i was
like let me chase you around with
half a cow what's your current
relationship
like with rupaul my current relationship
with rupaul is uh non-existent
the last time i saw her she told me off
and i said
youtube i haven't spoken to him in
years at this point but i have a feeling
if we ran into each other we would
probably
quote golden girls at each other and
laugh and
have a good time hey thank you buzzfeed
for buzzing about
us and our little podcast it's called
race chase sir it's on the forever dog
network
and we have a whole bunch of other
podcasts on the mom network
featuring a bunch of our favorite drag
queen friends
we're currently doing an eight episode
limited series
called pageant pod and it's all about
the history of drag pageant so get into
[Music]
it
[Music]
you